>> OPRAH WOULD BE A LOT OF
FUN.
I KNOW HER VERY WELL.
I DID ONE OF HER LAST SHOWS.
SHE HAD DONALD TRUMP HER
LAST WEEK AND SHE HAD DONALD
TRUMP AND MY FAMILY.
IT WAS VERY NICE.
I LIKE OPRAH.
I DON'T THINK SHE IS GOING
TO RUN.
>> THANKS GUYS.
>> I DON'T THINK SHE IS
GOING TO RUN.
>> THANKS, GUYS.
EARLIER TODAY RESPONDING TO
A REPORT OPRAH WINFREY
MIGHTEN THE SAVIOR FOR THE
DEMOCRATS IN 2020 SOMETHING
WITH REACTION THE HILL'S JOE
CONCHA AND PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
DAUGHTER-IN-LAW AND SENIOR
ADVISOR FOR TRUMP 2020 LARA
TRUMP IS WITH US.
CONGRATULATIONS.
I SAW PICTURES OF THE BABY.
>> THANK YOU.
>> Sean: THAT HAIR IS TO DIE
FOR.
AMAZING.
I THINK WHEN ALL OF THE
NOISE SETTLES AT THE END OF
THE DAY, THE FACT THAT WE
HAVE 2 MILLION FEWER PEOPLE
ON FOOD STAMPS, THE ECONOMY
IS TURNING AROUND, EVERY
INDICATOR, I WON'T GO
THROUGH THE LIST.
>> Sean: I HAVE 100 AND SOME
ODD ACCOMPLISHMENTS IN YEAR
ONE.
>> LISTEN, LET'S NOT FORGET
THAT IS WHAT THE STRATEGY IS
FOR 2020.
THAT IS WHAT MY
FATHER-IN-LAW IS GOING TO
RUN ON.
THE INCREDIBLE ACHIEVEMENTS.
WE HAVE ALREADY SEEN HE
HASN'T BEEN IN OFFICE FOR A
FULL YEAR AND LOOK AT WHAT
HE HAS DONE.
SO, I WOULD LOVE TO KNOW IF
OPRAH IS WHO WE HAVE TO RUN
AGAINST IN 2020.
SHE IS AN INCREDIBLE WOMAN.
I THINK SHE HAS MANY, MANY
ACCOMPLISHMENTS UNDER HER
BELT.
A GREAT TELEVISION HOST,
BUT, LET'S NOT FORGET DONALD
TRUMP IN 2016 DEFEATED 16
INCREDIBLE G.O.P.
CANDIDATES.
AND HILLARY CLINTON.
>> Sean: THE MEDIA LAUGHED
AT THE IDEA.
>> THEY SAID HE HAD NO SHOT.
IT'S GOING TO BE A LOT
HARDER, I THINK, TO RUN
AGAINST HIM IN 2020 THAN
ANYBODY IS SUGGESTING RIGHT
NOW.
OUT.
>> Sean: WHY IS THERE A
DESIRE ALWAYS IN THE MEDIA,
JOE, FOR THEIR SAVIOR?
BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT THEY
WAKE UP IN THE MORNING
SEEING WHAT THEY CAN HATE
DONALD TRUMP ABOUT ON ANY
GIVEN DAY.
>> SEAN, I THINK THE MEDIA
IS ADVOCATING FOR AN OPRAH
WINFREY CANDIDACY BECAUSE
THERE BE ANYTHING BETTER
FROM AN INFO TAKENMENT
PERSPECTIVE THAN WINFREY VS.
TRUMP IN 2020.
I JUST FIND THAT AMAZING
THAT THE SAME MEDIA THAT
DERIDED A POLITICAL NOVICE
AND A TV HOST FOR HAVING THE
AUDACITY TO RUN IN 2016 IS
ROUXING OVER THE PROSPECT OF
OPRAH WINFREY DOING IT IN
ALWAYS LIKE TO ASK YOU
BECAUSE I WATCH THE ATTACKS
ON YOUR FAMILY.
YOU KNOW THAT THEY ARE --
THEY ALWAYS WANTED TO GET
DONALD TRUMP.
THEY NEVER THOUGHT HE WOULD
WIN.
THEN HE WINS.
THEN THEY WERE ATTACKING
HIM.
A LOT OF IT IS BOOMERANGING
BACK.
IT'S HARD.
HOW HARD HAS IT BEEN ON YOUR
FAMILY.
SAY IT'S BEEN EASY.
IT'S HARD EVERY SINGLE DAY.
WE GET HIT FROM EVERY
FATHER-IN-LAW AND THE
INCREDIBLE JOB HE IS DOING
FOR THIS COUNTRY.
>> Sean: THE AGENDA IS GOOD
FOR THE COUNTRY, LARA.
>> IT IS.
NO TWO WAYS ABOUT IT COME
FEBRUARY 1st WHEN PEOPLE
HAVE A LOT FATTER PAYCHECK
EVEN PEOPLE THAT DIDN'T VOTE
GOOD THING.
>> Sean: THE BABY IS FOUR
MONTHS OLD, RIGHT?
>> ALMOST FOUR MONTHS OLD
THIS WEEK.
>> Sean: HAS HE BEEN IN THE
OVAL OFFICE YET?
>> HE HAS.
>> Sean: HAVE YOU TWEETED
THOSE PICTURES OUT.
>> ACTUALLY ERIC TWEETED THE
PICTURE OUT.
>> Sean: HAS THE SAME DESK.
>> I THINK A PICTURE BEHIND
THE DESK.
>> Sean: DEFINITELY WITH THE
HAIRSTYLE I SAW TODAY.
LAST WORD JOE CONCHA, I
THINK AT THE END OF THE DAY
THE NOISE GOES AWAY, IS THE
ECONOMY BETTER AND ARE WE
SAFER AS A COUNTRY AND HOW
MANY PROMISES DID HE KEEP?
>> WELL, THAT'S WHAT YOU
HAVE TO LOOK AT, SEAN, WHATS
WATT FIVE BIGGEST ISSUES
THAT VOTERS VOTED ON IN 2016
ACCORDING TO MOST POLLS.
ECONOMY, OKAY, WHICH YOU
COULD SAY THINGS ARE GOING
EXCELLENT AS YOU POINTED OUT
BEFORE.
JOBS, UNEMPLOYMENT AT
17-YEAR LOW.
ISIS THE CALIPHATE 98% OF
THIS DESTROYED.
AND THEN OBVIOUSLY
IMMIGRATION WHICH IS BEING
IF FOUR OF THOSE FIVE ARE
KEPT, I DON'T SEE WISCONSIN,
THOSE KEY STATES WHERE TRADE
AND ECONOMY WERE REALLY
IMPORTANT.
IT'S HARD TO SEE THAT